foreign
[Music]
the working week is over so it's time
for Keno check news there's news about
John Wick 5 and new Spider-Man movies
have also been announced further it
seems that the Expendables 4 is saying
goodbye to two great names there's also
info on the cast of Marvel's new
Fantastic Four movie and the live-action
reboot of How to Train Your Dragon but
enough talk about big announcements here
are the details
The Expendables franchise can primarily
impress with two things fast-paced
action and a cast full of Hollywood
greats one of the most popular figures
in the film series is Arnold
Schwarzenegger's character trench who
first played a major role in the second
part after many rumors that the 75 year
old will probably not return for the
upcoming fourth part there is now some
clarity following an interview the most
influential character next to
Schwarzenegger's role is clearly
Sylvester Stallone's Barney Ross a long
time leader of the versatile Riot Squad
is more or less the face of the
franchise and will probably bid his
final farewell in The Expendables 4. in
his place Jason Statham's character Lee
Christmas will take over as leader of
The Expendables who unlike the 76 year
old Stallone may still be able to show a
little more energy unlike Barney trench
had very little screen time in the
previous films and that will not change
as Schwarzenegger recently confirmed in
an interview with parade he is said to
have already decided after part 3 not to
be involved in the film series again it
would would have felt like telling the
same joke many times again he said
however this is definitely not meant to
be a refusal to work together in the
future the Terminator star can well
imagine working on a different project
with his longtime film Kali however it
is unclear whether this is more than
just an empty phrase either way we will
have to be braced for a few changes in
the upcoming fourth part the outcome of
whether we will witness the death of
Sylvester Stallone's Barney Ross or
whether the character will be given a
chance to enjoy his retirement is
eagerly awaited lavish and over-the-top
action scenes will no doubt be included
after all that's exactly what the film
series is known for The Expendables 4 is
set to be released on September 22nd
2023.
when you hear about Fantastic Four you
can't help but remember the unsuccessful
film from 2015 the reboot was not really
well received by either critics or fans
and ultimately put an end to the
potential film franchise it has been
known for some time that Marvel wants to
give it another shot with a new reboot
and as we've known since this week there
are said to be some actors involved who
were not previously thought of the story
of Fantastic Four is well known during a
space mission four scientists are
exposed to cosmic rays which eventually
give them a variety of superpowers and
so they first need to learn how to
handle them in the last movie from 2015
the characters were played by Jamie Bell
Kate Mara Miles Teller and Michael B
Jordan for the new reboot however the
cast will be entirely changed again as
the reliable marble Insider my time to
shine hello announced via Twitter the
cast list is said to be already in place
and to have a few surprises in store
accordingly Adam Driver is to appear as
Mr Fantastic Margot Robbie will take on
the role of Sue storm an after-sun actor
Paul Mezcal will play Johnny Storm the
cast is also expected to be completed by
musical star and Grammy Award winner
David Diggs who was expected to take on
the role of Ben Grimm aka the thing for
Marco Robbie the signing would also come
with the move from DC to Marvel as she
was previously starring as Harley Quinn
this project is already the fourth
attempt to successfully bring the comics
to the big screen after it was not
really crowned with much success in 2005
2007 and 2015 we are interested in
knowing what other news is still waiting
for us and we'll inform you as soon as
we know more about the next effort
Fantastic Four is expected to release on
February 14 2025.
at present the animated film Spider-Man
across the spider-verse is thrilling
both fans and critics in theaters while
the sequel is Raising anticipation for
the third film Beyond the spider verse
in the coming year there was now also
hot news about other new movies around
Spider-Man at the premiere of the latest
Spidey movie producer Amy Pascal
revealed to variety that they are
working on a live action Spider-Man
starring Miles Morales the relatively
new character made his comic book debut
in August of 2011. the first animated
film Spider-Man into the spider-verse
was released in 2018 in the video game
Spider-Man Miles Morales followed in
2020 after so many hits it's hardly
surprising that Sony now wants to
attempt a live-action movie producer
Avia Rod also added that a Spider Woman
movie was coming sooner than would
expect though he wasn't allowed to tell
us more yet Sony CEO Tim Rothman was
also secretive and jokingly said if I
told you I'd have to kill you Amy Pascal
further spoke about the next Spider-Man
movie with Tom Holland in Zendaya it is
still in the works but due to the writer
strike the project is currently on hold
they support the writer's request for
better working conditions and hope that
in agreement with Distributors will be
reached soon this is certainly upsetting
for the fans but at the same time it
seems as if we can expect numerous new
movies from the Spider-Man universe in
the future if these are leave a similar
quality as the recent films we can
likely look forward to some entertaining
cinematic adventures with Peter Parker
Miles Morales and others next up is
Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse it'll
be released on March 29 2024.
not only did John Wick 4 recently take
the popular franchise led by Keanu
Reeves to the magical box office
Milestone of one billion dollars but it
also raised big questions as to what
will happen next Joe Drake the chairman
of Lionsgate has now finally spoken out
about John Wick chapter 5. during
lionsgate's earnings call Drake first
announced that they plan to expand the
John Wick Universe extensively be it
into AAA video games television or other
spin-offs officially four projects are
currently in the works among them are
the movie ballerina the prequel series
the continental and indeed a John Wick
5. the fifth part is to emerge naturally
from the stories of the spin-offs
currently the film is in an early stage
of development but the biggest
unanswered question for fans remains
will Keanu Reeves return for John Wick 5
if Drake's statements are interpreted
correctly we will have to wait and see
what ballerina with Anna diaris and the
Continental will bring us at least for
the former cameos by Keanu Reeves have
already been confirmed what the
mysterious fourth John Wick project is
was not revealed by Joe Drake however
producer Erica Lee already said at the
end of March that a new film would be
announced roughly two months later
whether that is John Wick 5 or another
film is currently not clear we will keep
you up to date as always
10. How to Train Your Dragon the first
of a total of three very successful
animated films was released in cinemas
fans have been waiting for new footage
for several years now and it looks like
the time might be coming soon at least
as far as the cast is concerned the
production seems to be making some
progress and according to the latest
reports there is even a the last of a
star involved the fact that animated
movies can indeed be successfully
adapted into live action versions has
been demonstrated several times in
recent years but there is also the other
side of the coin many fans are rather
skeptical about such projects in
particular with regard to those from
Disney whether rival Universal can be
convincing in this respect is something
we will see with the live adaptation of
How to Train Your Dragon the cast of the
two main human characters has now been
announced while the black phone actor
Mason Thames will take on the role of
lovable hiccup Nico Parker will slip
into the role of Astrid Parker is
already known from HBO's The Last of a
series where she plays the daughter of
protagonist Joel according to current
information Parker will not only be a
mere companion to her husband but will
also show off her dragon training skills
the script and the directing of the
Remake will be done by Dean devlaw who
was also in charge of the old films and
the animated classic Lilo and Stitch
this will be his first live action movie
shooting for the live-action remake of
How to Train Your Dragon will start this
summer with the theatrical release
scheduled for March 14 2025.
looking for more content about future
movies we gotcha this week we uploaded
two movie previews one being Mufasa the
prequel to Disney's fantastic The Lion
King and the other one being Kingdom of
the Planet of the Apes the fourth
installment of the Planet of the Apes
franchise both movies are slated for
release in 2024 so be sure to check out
our videos in order to raise your
excitement even more thanks for watching
and see you next week for more kenocheck
news
thank you
[Music]
foreign